what's going on ready jack nation it's
Greg Galvez here and it's John Humphrey
over here so we're catching up on
trailers movie trailers this week is
John and I took the weekend to ourselves
attend to a couple things but while
we're catching up one of the pledge
chairs on our patreon is that whatever
you request them because we get tons of
requests and we only go by what is like
being requested in multiple times by you
know several people not just one but
like several yeah a few people are not
factored it out one of the reward tiers
is that whatever you request we will
definitely do and today's for a patron
of the day
Andrew Terpening OOP Terpening you know
I have open have an uncle Andrew he has
a son named Peter and a daughter named
Andrea cool they are the most
frustrating side of my family
oh no I'm sorry with a steel steel so my
uncle Andrews a thief now they don't say
my name Andy yeah Wesley Snipes the
recall is what he wants by the hood
interesting I know nothing about trailer
came out a month ago we knew - perfect
for catching up yes violent language and
some nudity love oh love unit okay clean
living today doing one bacteria he
answers the bread
I know that guy yeah bring your boos
time bridging bad guy yeah but I do
personal loss and coordinator disorder
some type of easier large shift why kind
of Leslie's Maximus leave a shot with
why
[Music]
wait what about the meteors what would
not happen evil then what Lucania God
but the crazy dude from the gas station
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
darling
[Music]
see the conduct of Wapping
[Music]
living about their districts or
integration activity
freaking me out another days before
nobody coming back man after Breaking
Bad he just has a jump at the chance to
work with Wesley Snipes oh yeah it's
like it's like an even better ass Walter
white short in a way you know cuz
they're both bald and they got the
goatee and half the conservation skills
you have they're definitely definitely I
I can't tell what scales this movie
exists cuz it just looks like something
this movie looks great and you're
sharpening directed it who is that
patron of the day he directed it yeah
oh I did not know that yeah we can talk
[ __ ] about I'm just joking you direct it
we do our man if he directed that would
be like wow I was very impressed this is
the tuition youtubers get into yeah well
you can't just watch your friends with
you but I'm thinking like wow dude this
is just something humanity not all these
people know is actually amazing I've
been looking at it on its own it's quite
a totally confusing trick yeah it's
going on a trip bunch of teenagers
Walters kid they go with AC a meteor or
something in the cloud and then there's
like scary Wesley Snipes it looks like
Oh Matt maybe West's time see revealer
what about that meteor think come to
find out the both connected is something
about meteorites Wesley Snipes is livid
for very business bad six year it's
almost ridiculous yeah in a very
enjoyable if someone is putting it on in
the background I will sit down get high
and watch it with your with a patent to
kind of build this is that's where
everything kind of averages out proving
it's like there was some moments where I
was genuinely kind of impressed like wow
alien set doesn't look at that actually
yeah and I almost feel like the title
card get better and worse when the food
more and less cheesy yeah it certainly
looks like a distinct movie yeah yeah
like Wesley almost like kind of I was
reminded of like Evil Dead I was a
reminder don't greet almost for milling
is he's just gonna be like a badass who
lives in the woods and start attacking
these people 10 Cloverfield yeah 10
Cloverfield Lane like it looks like so
many movies and I can't tell although
the Crystal school dark skies like the
Fourth Kind look a little I'm not gonna
lie you that doesn't look like a good
movie no but it doesn't look like a good
movie at all but it looks like it could
be actually fun maybe yeah but like half
the time it maybe not I don't feel like
I don't think it's actually aware of
what it is and that makes for the best
kind of fun second I cannot tell because
it doesn't look bored that's one thing
yeah yeah I think we should waste
something that's not boring even if it's
terrible as long as I'm not bored
you put boring in there then we got Pro
tears I feel like we've enjoyed this I
mean Wesley Snipes is mad for a guy for
a guy man would happen to are like 90s
action stars man yeah like Stallone the
only one still makes the feature film
beep it was like he's a good actor
yeah he's arguably one of the better and
he can actually fight he looks like he's
very committed here like I was compelled
if nothing else by the weird moments he
was in I camera this is before or after
blade but did you know he tried getting
a black panther movie made that he wrote
the feature film scripts can sell what I
to pitch it because he wanted to star in
it I did not know that
we got blade and blade the badass
memorable I'm told but the Ricoh moment
again the recall this is also like and I
guess he probably definitely made this
after breaking bad because now I'm
wondering like it is RJ Mitte like a big
character or is he gonna be like a side
character or something like I can't tell
what the looks like the main guy I guess
I yeah he is the main guy out of the
group of guys most relatable one I guess
yeah he's a more popular one you know
those emails for advanced screenings for
these movies military hood well yeah
basically tonight with an RJ Mitte who's
that but sometimes in these like weirder
kinds of movies like you'll see that
we're going really play up the big-name
they got to be a supporting character
because that's all the budget could
afford for yeah there was in which it
does look like he's the main character
but I found myself wondering at times
like there are so many things going on
like is he actually not gonna be as as
much as we think he is look look Andrew
you wanted our pinion on it
I'm not going to go out of my way to go
watch this movie like I said I'm one of
my life FileMaker buddies Andrew gold I
thought it was gonna turn into a parody
like it so yeah like I thought that's
what they were doing that's what I mean
by how it doesn't seem self-aware it's
in the uncanny valley of self-aware for
me where is it times them like now it
seems like they know what they're doing
and at times they don't that looks like
you're saying yourselves pretty serious
yeah but it never doesn't look fun is
the one thing on youbut and if there's
nothing I can say trailers are always
accurate and they're portrayed a little
bit movie I feel like I just also think
how does it click the way that trailer
progressed
anyway are you guys excited for the
recall party you're gonna pay money to
watch this
I tell me if you are please subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell John is dead John Aubrey on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
Blum House of course
shout out to Andrew Terpening you know
what his I like to do for shout outs I
like to look up what names Terpening
names meaning habitual name for someone
who lived in that house distinguished by
the sign of a coin I have so much
material I work off of with that I'm
going to save it for a later day
Terpening novels worth of coins